[Music]
a free kebab for every job
this berlin initiative was just one of 1
500 campaigns in germany's vaccination
action week last week
the result 500 000 people were
vaccinated for the first time with a
free jab at mosques supermarkets and
football pitches
but is that enough
just one in six people in the over 60s
risk group has been vaccinated
if a highly contagious delta variant
starts to spread among those most
vulnerable germany's intensive care
units could be under serious pressure
welcome to our curvy 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin good to have you
with us and it's mind-boggling isn't it
19 months into the pandemic with
millions of kobet 19 deaths around the
world and people in wealthy nations like
germany still hesitate to get vaccinated
just about 63 percent of the country's
population is immunized too little say
experts now the government tries to
change that with a carrot and stick
approach
getting the shot during your lunch break
without appointment and free of charge
this little stall in berlin kuezbeck is
part of a special week-long drive in
germany the idea to make it as easy as
possible to get vaccinated
the organizers say it's working
we've had over 80s who received their
third vaccinations various people
getting their first vaccinations so a
mixture of people who really decided
spontaneously while shopping and people
who came here after hearing about it in
the media
all over germany health workers are
trying to reach people who have yet to
get a shot as the country's vaccination
campaign sputters
germany wants 75 of the population to be
immunized against the coronavirus
heading into the fall to prevent a
deadly surge of infections
so far only just over 62 percent have
received the necessary shots
german president frank walter steinmeier
has also stepped in to do some
convincing
now it's important to tell people again
it's not just about you when you decide
against vaccination you're not only
deciding against yourself and risking
your own health you are also risking the
health of others
most covet 19 patients in intensive care
in germany are now unvaccinated the
government has stressed time and again
that it's not planning on making
vaccinations mandatory but several of
germany's 16 states have started
restricting access to certain venues for
people who haven't received their shots
that's a persuasive reason for some to
get the job like here in munich
i'm fed up with these restrictions
always having to be tested and all that
and for him there's even a reward
waiting a right on the ferris wheel well
germany has a population of about 80
million how many shots were given so far
well in its latest report germany's
robert koch institute counts 105 million
seven thousand three hundred and thirty
two covet vaccine doses administered
that was until sunday well i was at the
doctors today and uh there were quite a
few people waiting to get vaccinated
there so the number is rising albeit
slowly too slowly perhaps
let's ask professor gernot max he's the
president of the german
interdisciplinary association of
critical care and emergency medicine at
the university clinic in achen good to
have you with us uh professor and
perhaps let's start by
please uh if you could remind us again
what percentage of the population needs
to be immunized to keep the virus at
least under control so we can get back
to a normal life
well it is really true that every
citizen who is
vaccinated more is is positive so i mean
we are in the moment fully vaccinated by
63 percent
and we are aiming at least towards 75 i
mean 85 would be even better but uh
let's say 10 law would mean
that more people are protected and less
people
getting sick or even to the icu
so what you make of last week's
vaccination action week 500 000 more
people got vaccinated but that's not
enough is it
this is true this is not enough but on
the other hand side 500 000 citizens
more vaccinated is
wonderful
we need really to be persuasive and
convincing people and getting them
better informed and invite them to
to get vaccinated for themselves and and
for for the society
and
then we really need to inform i think
many people still haven't understood
how dangerous a
covet 19 disease really could be for for
everybody yeah you you mentioned
something there because uh
many anti-vaxxers believe that it's
actually safer to get infected with
cyrus kobe 2 safer than to get
vaccinated is there a medical argument
to sustain that belief
well this is definitely not true
from the scientific point of view first
of all let's start with the intensive
care environment in the first two waves
uh more than 50 percent of our patients
who we need to ventilate
diet in germany
and
in the third wave we had about 40 so
this is really
a deadly disease when it comes to the
the severest forms
when when people need us as intensivists
so it's really
dangerous for your own life when you're
not vaccinated and then certain in in
addition
what we see in many patients even in
those who have not really
many symptoms when they're acutely ill
with the
virus
they are having the potential of
developing long covet syndrome and this
is
having fatigue and having neurologic
symptoms so it is it is really
a disease nobody wants to have and it's
definitely
when you weigh the risk and benefit of
vaccination against the coronavirus
from the scientific point of view from
the intensivist point of view the
benefits are outweighing the risks at
all
and of course all of those things the
fact that millions of people died around
the world already that you can get
seriously ill and even if you're not you
could suffer from long covet and we
don't even know all the symptoms yet all
of that is known yet people are still
hesitant now looking at the current
situation in hospitals especially icus
and the current vaccination rate in
germany what's in store for us this
autumn and winter
well this is a difficult question in the
moment we have just about 1500 icu
patients
this is a situation we can handle but
it's still if you think we have more
than 90 non-vaccinated patients so
it could be far less and
we um
we know from last year that there is a
seasonal effect of the corona virus
and therefore we do expect that when
people are getting more and more into
their rooms in the to their homes
uh that the um
there's a risk that we have an increase
in the infection rate and the incidence
and hence
excuse me in the end also in in the rate
of
patients who we need to care for on icus
so we we expect really more patients in
the winter time all right professor
gerald marks from the university clinic
in achen thank you so much and yourself
stay healthy
thank you ever so much for yourself
and time for more of your questions now
and here to answer them is our science
correspondent derek williams
what makes a pandemic a pandemic coveted
19 is one but the flu apparently isn't
why
this is pretty confusing i admit so so
maybe it's best to start with some basic
definitions um the first term
used in connection with the appearance
of a disease whether it's caused by a
novel pathogen or by a pathogen we've
seen before
is outbreak
which is kind of a catch-all description
for any
sudden rise in the number of cases
outbreaks can happen in a particular
geographic region
but they can also cross international
borders they can occur unexpectedly or
or or intermittently like for example
ebola outbreaks in parts of sub-saharan
africa
or they can be regular occurrences like
seasonal outbreaks of flu
an epidemic on the other hand describes
the situation when an outbreak expands
and the disease begins spreading quickly
to
a large number of people both within
individual countries and across
international borders um the sars
epidemic of 2002 and 2003 which was
eventually contained after killing
hundreds of people
it's often cited as an example of an
epidemic
a pandemic is what an epidemic turns
into when it spins out of control and
infecting an even larger number of
people at an expanding rate and hitting
populations globally
ratcheting up the number of deaths in in
a big way um often that kind of wildfire
spread occurs
because the pathogen is a new one or is
is maybe one that's reappeared suddenly
after a long hiatus um so most people
have never been exposed to it before and
and have no immunity um flu pandemics do
occur regularly just think of the one
that killed between 50 and 100 million
people worldwide
over a three year period after the end
of the first world war
however that was caused by a novel flu
virus that was quite different
than the flu viruses circulating in
populations at the time causing
normal levels of endemic flu um those
endemic flu bugs also cause disease of
course and and they also kill people
but mostly
seasonally in different parts of the
world and and in relatively predictable
numbers
which is what distinguishes them in
epidemiological terms from for instance
a pandemic causing pathogen uh like sars
kovi-2
and just briefly to indonesia where a
40-year-old counselor is dressing up as
a superhero called iso man to give
children in self-isolation some relief
from pandemic sadness and boredom aegos
with donarko slides into a spiderman
costume pulls on a mask
to give hope to kids
a psychological lift in central java
province
that's all thanks for watching
[Music]